ja wir kommen zur heutigen sitzung in
der wir uns vor allem mit christian
jakob kraus fassen werden einem recht
unbekannten denke dass 18 jahrhunderts
und dann noch vielleicht am ende noch
kurz mit carl christian schmidt der ist
auch ein sehr unbekannter kardialer der
allerdings ein bisschen wichtiger ist in
der philosophiegeschichte als der
christian jakob kraus was hat es mit
diesen auf sich beide banker beziehen
sich auf diesen philosophen hier
und wenn sie die letzte sitzung gesehen
haben ob rechts manch ein link zu dieser
sitzung hinein in youtube dann erinnern
sie sich das war johann august heinrich
ulrich und dieser denke hatte ein welt
geschrieben von dem wir auszüge
diskutiert hatten und dass sie erneut
theologie oder über freiheit und
notwendigkeit
und wie schon das letzte mal gezeigt
hatte bedeutete theologie dieses wort
bedeutet eigentlich nichts anderes als
freiheits leere
es geht also darum wie wir freiheit
verstehen müssen und zwar ganz konkret
wie freiheit und notwendigkeit
miteinander zusammenhängen und das ist
die frage nach dem kompatibel ist muss
frage kompatibel ist muss und ulrich
hatte eine klare these ich gehe auch
noch mal auf diese thesen bisschen näher
ein
in dieser sitzung was hat würde ich
geschrieben ullrich hat vor allem eine
kritik der fast nämlich am kant
moralphilosophie genauer gesagt an seine
freiheits theorie und diese kritik sieht
so aus nach ulrich versucht kann
vergeblich freiheit mit natur
determinismus zu vereinigen
es gibt nach ulrich keinen mittelweg
zwischen freiheit und notwendigkeit
sie nennen sich dass ulrich sagte der
linie aus also die nähe dieser
naturforscher müsste verkannt an neue
art einführen kann passt in keine
schublade mit seiner freiheit theorie
und das hat er glaube ich sehr treffend
gesagt nach wie vor auch heutzutage
streiten sich die forscherinnen und
forscher darüber wo dann kann jetzt
einzuordnen ist in den verschiedenen
schubladen der aktuellen freiheits
debatte
wir hatten auf youtube eine debatte
darüber ein bisschen ist jetzt ist jetzt
ullrich ist jetzt kann ein kompatibel
ist
oder ist ein inkompatibel ist die frage
ist nicht geklärt das sage ich ganz
offen ich glaube er ist eher ein
kompatibel ist aber natürlich nicht ganz
genau heute sehe aber er sagt immer
wieder es geht darum zu vereinigen
freiheit natur determinismus und das
scheint mir doch ein kompatibles muss zu
rechtfertigen dann noch eine
interessante kritik von ullrich an kant
die transzendentale freiheit um dies
erkannt zentral geht diese trans en
thale freiheit die muss um gute und böse
handlungen bewirken zu können
veränderungen erleiden und damit derzeit
ausgesetzt sein ulrich fragte sich wie
kann es sein dass dasselbe vermögen dir
eine praktische fenster die vernunft
einmal zu guten handlungen führt und
einmal zur bösen handlung für das ist ja
so dass wir unterschiedlich gut oder
schlecht handel in unserem leben und
wenn das der trans zentralen freiheit
oder der vernunft als ein vermögen zu
zeichnen ist dann müssen wir darin ein
wandel warum sitzen an ein wandel kann
natürlich nur stattfinden wenn er
zeitlich strukturiert ist und das hatte
kant gerade bestritten dass die tanz in
thale freiheit zeitlich verfahren
ja und das wird eben dieses punktes dass
er möge der praktischen vernunft im fall
des guten angewendet werden muss
im fall des bösen nicht also die wirkt
ein halt die praktische vernunft wenn
sie wird dann motiviert sie uns mit dem
gefühl beachtung dann lässt sie uns das
gute erkennen
das heißt sie muss ja von irgendetwas in
gang gesetzt werden ein vermögen ist ja
nicht ein autonomer akteure
es sind ein vermögen muss von einem
subjekt gebraucht aktiviert oder eben
missbraucht oder nicht aktiviert werden
nicht aktualisiert werden
das heißt ulrich fragt dann sehr
konsequent ja wenn eben wie einmal guten
analyse handeln dann muss das doch mit
dem intelligent character zu tun haben
der hinter dem vermögen steht an dem
subjekt dass die vernunft gebraucht und
rühre ich hatte dann die these vertreten
die ich sehr originell finde das
intelligente charakter eigentlich wenn
er jetzt eben der grund für diese
vernunft äußerung ist dass der
eigentlich wenn er jetzt nicht zeitlich
verortet werden kann dass der eigentlich
nur eine natur notwendigkeit in anderen
verstanden darstellen
man muss dazu sagen dass ullrich immer
auch den satz vom zureichenden gründe
gelten lassen möchte er war nämlich von
leibnitz sehr beeinflusst vom
zureichenden gründe
also alles hat eine ursache alles ist
determiniert und demnach würde der
integrierte charakter eben die anwendung
der vernunft im guten oder bösen sinne
vor der terminierung und diese vor der
termination wäre dann eigentlich auch
ein natur notwendigkeit in einem anderen
verstand ich habe das deswegen jetzt so
betont weil das führt auf den nächsten
denker den wir am ende vielleicht noch
kurz zu wort kommen lassen werden können
nämlich carl-christian er hat schmid
schmid und der hatte eine theorie
formuliert und die ist die theorie dass
intelligent fatalismus fatalismus und
diese interview fatalismus der bedeutet
einfach nur wir sind nur frei dann wenn
wir moralisch gut handeln und das ist
natürlich hier ganz klar verbunden mit
dieser notwendigkeit anders verstanden
der fatalismus und schmid war auch ein
schüler von ulrich als liegt so nahe
dass er durch ihn beeinflusst wurde
ja so viel zum hintergrund und heute
wollen wir uns mit diesem denke hier
befassen jetzt ganz unbekannt aber darum
sollten diesem seminar geht es geht um
johann august heinrich bzw
es geht um den
chaos der auch eine rolle spielt und was
war mit dem kreis der fall
wie bewertet kraus und kann die wir
werden die ulrichs eheleute rio logi das
ist eine frage inwiefern verteidigen
kann und kaufte idee einer trans
zentralen freiheit ist diese
verteidigung überzeugend das sind so die
fragen und ich kann schon vorweg sagen
dass dieser kraus ein schüler von kant
war und das wird von kant zu dieser
rezension dieser kritik diese leute
renault khedira ziemlich kritisch mit
kanten gegangen ist ihn dazu motiviert
hat und davor möchte ich aber noch hier
einen kurzen text von kant selbst aus
einem nachlass präsentieren worin er
schon einen wurf für eine kritische
rezension dieser ältere logi gegen hat
das ist die so genannte vorarbeit zu
dieser ulrich reitz zentrum von kraus
und jetzt sagen kann zu dieser leute
biologie diese abhandlung ist nützlich
der verfasser weist gründlich wie die
freiheit gedacht werden müsse wenn man
die existenz der dinge sofern sie in der
zeit dominiert ist als die art des
dinges an sich selbst zu existieren
sieht sie ist bluse natur mechanismus
nun findet er ulrich schwierigkeiten
eine andere art existieren jeden
desselben dieses als in der zeit
bestimmung anzunehmen und nimmt daher
den determinismus an gibt ihm auch ein
so mit der moral verträgliches ansehen
als sich tun lässt wenn ich aber es
nicht sonst als jene schwierigkeiten
abhalten so lassen sich diese leicht
heben also es geht darum wir haben nicht
die gesamte erläutere logi gelesen es
geht konkret darum dass ullrich in
seinem buch noch eine these vertreten
hatte nämlich dass der terrorismus mit
der moral verträglich
dass wir eben die moral weiterhin
aufrechterhalten könnte unterscheidung
von gut und böse auch dann wenn wir
einen determinismus vertreten wie ihn
eben oder ich vertrete ohne jetzt diese
unterscheidung zu machen die e bekannt
macht der scheidung zwischen ding an
sich wurde den internen charakter und
der erscheinung
diese unterscheidung die 90 bzw
intuitive charakter und erscheinung wenn
die ist der stein des anstoßes gewesen
diese unterscheidung hat gänzlich
gebrochen mit den damalig
vorherrschenden theorie dass die an sich
ist nämlich zeitlos und die alles was in
erscheinung ist das ist zeitlich
deswegen auch eben determiniert durch
die natur gesetzlichkeiten so diese
unterscheidung die möchte einfach ulrich
nicht mitmachen
und dennoch möchte er bekannt geben sagt
ein konsequenter moralist sein also ein
konsequenter vertreter der moral
so also kann notiert das und sagt also
ulrich möchte offensichtlich diese
unterscheidung nicht mitmachen es ist zu
wünschen dass erkannt dass der
gründliche helfer faser die übrige
schwierigkeit ich würdige arbeit des
kantigen systems ebenso behandelt wie
hier nämlich zu zeigen wie man allen
schwierigkeiten wenn ich außer der
freiheit die reine vernunft sonst findet
abhelfen können auch ohne jene
grundsätze des unterschiedes sinnlichen
und intellektuellen anzunehmen und dann
alle erst ein würfe gegen das system
machen denn so kann man am besten ziehen
wo die hilfe zu suchen sei also und das
heißt kann möchte jetzt ulrich nochmal
in der rezension
zeigen was die wichtige unterscheidung
von ding an sich oder internet dem
charakter und erscheinung bedeutet in
dieser vorstellung zarte erscheinung
sagt kant gibt es keine scheu keine
zurechnung weil die rede nur ist von
physischen erklärungs gründen nach den
etwas geschehen ist nicht von
moralischen nach welchen etwas was bloß
in der idee liegt und was nicht
geschehen ist hätte geschehen sollen
aber nun tritt statt des physischen
gesetzes das moralisch statt der
physischen freiheit ein wunderlicher
laden zuerkannt die moralische und statt
der erklärung der zurechnung die
zurechnung 1
die handlungen wenn sie in demselben
sind in beiden fällen genommen werden
zahlen widersprechen sich oder filme die
freiheit geht verloren oder die natur
soll beides sein sie muss dieselbe
handlung desselben subjekts ärztlich und
naturgesetzen stehend und dasselbe wesen
als verstandes wesen doch auch in
anziehung derselben handlung nicht in
natur gesetzen unterworfen und doch
davon der konzer das ist jetzt noch mal
eine sehr gute zusammenfassung von kant
wie ich finde
wo er nochmals sein ganzes system des
trans zentralismus erklärt er sagt es
ist also der meinung und ich habe das
einfach nicht verstanden diese
unterscheidung die kann die kritik der
reinen vernunft vorgenommen hatte ich
nach oben rechts sind auch noch mal ein
link zu dem video wo wir diese theorie
gehandelt haben also nach kant gibt es
in der erscheinung also allem was
zeitlich und räumlich ist keine reue
also ist einfach ein moralischer begriff
und auch keine zurechnung zu rechnen ist
auch eine moralische begriff gibt es nur
physische erklärungs gründe und die
erklärungs gründet die hänge neben mit
der erklärung in dem es wieder zusammen
dass es kausal der termin ist
erklärung jetzt sind sie erinnern sich
vielleicht oder kommt vielleicht drauf
es gibt ein philosoph und er ins detail
und ihr habt die unterscheidung zwischen
erklären und verstehen gemacht
mehr sagt erklären das tun die
naturwissenschaften verstehen tun die
geistes ist schon
und hier ist es jetzt ganz ähnlich also
die moralität die kann nur verstanden
werden die ist was rationales im sinne
der praktische hilft die natur
wissenschaft kann moral nicht richtig
erklären sie kann ihm nur erklärungs
gründe von dem vorbringen was räumlich
und zeitlich ist und jetzt will eben
hand sein sie dürfen nicht in dem selben
sinn genommen werden sondern es muss
unterschieden werden zwischen einem
subjekt unter naturgesetzen dass es eben
das objekt als erscheinung und dasselbe
wesen als verstandes wesen das ist dann
praktisch die interaktive charakter
und dass hier wieder ist der kompatibel
ist muss in anziehung derselben handlung
steht die handlung unter naturgesetzen
und auch nicht und hier ist mir noch was
eingefallen was in der gegenwärtigen
debatte
zentral ist diese erklärungs gründe es
gibt von wilfried ilias haben sie
vielleicht schon gehört
er spricht von einem space of reasons
also raum der gründe der sus raum der
ursachen und der raum der gründe ist der
raum in dem eben freiheit möglich ist
sei es versteht jetzt gründe im sinne
von sprachlicher praxis also es geht
darum sprachliche implikationen
sprachliche umgang
das ist ja noch um die gründe der raum
der ursachen der hat eine ganz andere
strukturen also das glaubt jetzt kannte
ich noch mal erklären zu müssen wo ich
habe so kennt nicht diesen unterschied
verstanden
weiter sagt kann dass ich hier mit
moralität und zurechnung ganz wohl reime
das kann man nur mit umkehrung aller
moralischen prinzipien glauben zur porta
zion im station ist die zurechenbarkeit
es erkannt wird erfordert wenn die
handlung böse ist dass sie dem selben
augenblick ist dem subjekt
ich sei sie zu unterlassen das ist jetzt
wieder diese wenn sie sich noch mehr
erinnern dass ullrich kritisiert hatte
dass es in demselben augenblick das kann
sich so verhalten aber es kann sie auch
so verhalten
ja es ist hat diese eine gewisse
indifferenz die freiheit der wahl sich
für gegensätzliches entscheiden zu
können
und das hatte wurde ich kritisiert ja
und ist sie gut dass keine andere
bestimmte ursachen die bills bestimmung
bewirkt haben
also hier leben noch mal dass hier eben
das objekt sich bewusst sein muss es
können und auch ist soll wer sie gemacht
werden dass es eben vor hat damit nun
wenn die handlung geschehen ist so
findet er dass es unter den umständen
darin er vorher war wirklich unmöglich
war dass es mit der zeit besser werden
konnte also war es möglich selbst nach
den umständen darin ja vorher war besser
zu werden
in der aussicht auf die handlung und war
doch unmöglich dass er anders hat werden
können in der rücksicht wenn er vorher
alle umstände hätte eingesehen der inner
war hätte er schon zum voraus sehen das
zwar nach sein vermögen in abstrakter
betrachtet die besser möglich nach den
umständen aber nicht ganz unmöglich sei
welches er nur hinter nach wenn das was
er nicht vorausgesehen ist nach
physischen gesetzen schließen kann als
singles kann argumentiert hier nicht
ganz ganz schlüssig und ganz
zusammenhängt das sind jetzt nur notizen
zu einer rezension von ulrichs
deswegen will ich jetzt auch ein
bisschen weiter fahren wir nach aber das
physische system der realität was eben
ulrich versucht hatte zu entwickeln also
dass wir eben nur auf basis der
erscheinungen diesem determinismus
moralität aufrechterhalten könnte das
nennt kann das physische systeme
qualität das sei nach was ulrich
vertritt ein kontinuierlicher
widerspruch und das eingebildete sollen
die umstellung mögen sein welche sie
wollen ist doch wenigstens eine
einbildung von freiheit aber auch nicht
mehr
also eher auf der ebene erscheinungen
können wir nach kant gar keine moral wir
konnten wir brauchen so was wie ein die
an sich also hier nochmal was die
physische notwendigkeit ist mit dem
sittlichen gesetze des menschen nicht zu
vereinigen
hier könnte man jetzt sagen ja ist er
dann doch ein inkompatibel ist kant wenn
er sagt die physische notwendigkeit mit
dem sittengesetz ist nichts auf
einfachen sondern ein kompromiss
dem ungeachtet kann die ist auch nicht
abgeschafft werden also die physische
notwendigkeit also muss eine art der
relation des subjekts zu den
begebenheiten der sinn welt davon die
handlung eine ist aufgefunden werden die
mit der physischen notwendigkeit und
zugleich auch mit der unabhängigkeit von
ihr bestehen kann
nun kann das dasein das leben in der
zeit nur mit der physischen
notwendigkeit bestehen also muss das
dasein derselben als nicht in der zeit
bestimmte betrachtet werden also eben
hier wieder
dieser gedanke wenn wir ebenso ein
kompatibles muss er nach erlangen wollen
dann müssen wir die raum und zeit logik
die wir gewohnt sind anders denken wir
müssen uns als moralische wesen
letztendlich zeitlos denken zumindest
wenn es um unsere trans zentrale
freiheit geht und hier sagt eben kann
das hab ich nicht verstand
ja ich habe jetzt hier nochmal eine
weitere folie und jetzt ist das richtige
bild hier noch nicht dran
es geht jetzt hier um den christian
jakob kraus und da sag ich jetzt noch
mal was dazu er studierte an der
universität königsberg und sie wissen
alle kannte hatte dort gelehrt er wurde
ein schüler kannst und er beauftragte
kraus eine rezension von ulrichs
eheleuten zu verfassen
und jetzt wollen wir noch ganz kurz in
dieser rezension hineinschauen und zu
überlegen inwiefern jetzt kraus als
dieser schüler von kant würde ich ebenso
kritisiert oder aber noch ein paar
andere gedanken hat jetzt sagt kraus
folgendes der zusammenhang des
physischen und moralischen menschen
insofern er eben dieselben handlungen
nicht nur nach verhältnisse der
bestimmte natur notwendigkeit sondern
auch in beziehung auf eine unbedingte
selbsttätigkeit und zwar beides zusammen
gedenken zahl überschreitet alle fassung
seines geistes der je nachdem er es
versucht diese handlung entweder gemäss
die bedürfnisse des verstandes als natur
bestimmt oder gemäß dem erfordernis der
moralität als durch freiheit
hervorgebracht anzunehmen bald einsieht
dass er in ersterem fall das wesen der
sittlichkeit und im anderen ein
gebrauchtes verstandes aufgeben müssen
und so hat er keines und beiden sich
aufgeben wird gewahr wird dass hier ein
geheimnis vor allem die kraus hat jetzt
die tendenz das was kant in der trans
zentralen kritik macht das als etwas
mysteriöses aufzufassen als ein
geheimnis also diese vereinbarkeit diese
kompatibilität das ist verkannt für
kraus ein problem und das ist natürlich
problematisch weil sie müssen überlegen
man muss ja auch gute gründe geben für
eine theorie und kann ich einfach nur
sagen es handelt sich hier um ein
geheimnis weil dann könnte ullrich zu
recht sagen ja es geht mir aber nicht um
geheimnis geht mir hoch begründung für
das official begründung
ja das ist vielleicht ein gewisser
schwachpunkt von kraus ich fahre mal ein
bisschen weiter graues wirft jetzt
ulrich vor dass er keinen richtigen
freiheitsbegriff habe nämlich ulrich
würde und der freiheit
praktisch so was verstehen was auch sich
verbessern diese was also im sinne einer
pv eines perfektionismus nach lebens zu
verstehen sei das hält jetzt raus nicht
überzeugend und jetzt eben habe nun der
übergang von diesen namen freiheit die
nichts als natur notwendigkeit ist zu
der dann von ganz abgeschnittenen
moralität oder von diesem unabhängigen
können zudem absolut im soll der
übergang jahr statt den zu zeigen worauf
doch eben alles an kam klagte verfasser
nämlich ulrich der begriff des absoluten
sollens der freilich der eigentliche
klassiker ist für den tierischen
journalisten ist sei eine der schwersten
in der ganzen wahl des untersuchen er
sich auf eine andere zeit vorbehalten
also hier sagt jetzt sehr kritisch das
was ullrich jetzt hier unter freiheit
versteht das ist nur eine freiheit dem
namen nach jedoch sei eine pseudo pseudo
freiheit
sie können sich denken wie kann diese
freiheit genannt hätte die freiheit
eines braten wenn das da hatten wir auch
in der ersten sitzung darüber gesprochen
also das wäre nur so eine art von
handlungsfreiheit aber nicht eine starke
form von willensfreiheit es ist nur die
handlungsfreiheit
das ist das läuft darauf hinaus kraus
mit kant sagt ulrich kann nur
handlungsfreiheit vertreten mit seinem
determinismus er kann eben gerade nicht
willensfreiheit starken sind vertreten
ja das ist so
diese theorie und jetzt gibt es eben bei
ullrich soll diese these dass eine
handlung von am anfang gesehen noch
nicht notwendig war
es hat folgendes wenn der verfasser das
leugnen wollte so müsste er behaupten
dass zum beispiel das tun und lassen der
jenen seite der einwohner bewohner von
jena im verflossenen jahr jetzt nach dem
ende des jahres durchaus notwendig so
wie es war also jetzt gesehen notwendig
vor dem anfangen desselben aber nicht
notwendig so wie es war
gewesen sei und auf gleiche weise alle
handlungen aller menschen in der zeit
folge zwar zurück von b nach a gesehen
unmöglich anders aber vorwärts m a nach
b gesehen ganz anders möglich gewesen
sein welche nach einem urteil über eine
sache objektiv genommen zugleich wahr
und falsch wäre eine unbegreiflichkeit
die größe ist als diejenige welche durch
umgehung der sittlichen freiheit
vermieden werden sollte und die nicht
etwa nur der verfasser auf see geraten
ist sondern auf demselben wege trotz
aller vorsicht jedermann unabänderliche
weise am ende sich verwickeln muss also
was sagt jetzt kraus was ulrich gemacht
habe es geht also um diese relation am a
nach b und einmal von been a
die zeit ist jetzt in diese richtung und
jetzt wird klaus ullrich vor
hier in diesem fall im zweiten falle
nämlich eben von diesem webinar gesehen
da sei es notwendig so also rückblickend
rückblickend hätte sich alles so
notwendig ergeben aber aus der anderen
richtung als von a nach b also bevor die
handlung eingetreten war
da sei es eben möglich gewesen
das sei die freiheit vorwärts gesehen
von vorwärts von a nach b gesehen dass
sie ganz anders möglich gewesen also
möglich im sinne dieser alternativen
entscheidungen ja und das ist natürlich
da hat jetzt erst recht das widerspricht
sich ja ich kann nicht einmal sagen das
ereignis b was erfolgt ist notwendig
zugleich aber sagen das ereignis hsb
vorweg geht ist möglicher hatten wir
verschiedene möglichkeiten und kraus
wird ebenso argumentieren dass es seit
diesen widerspruch hier
den können wir nur dann auflösen wenn
wir so was wie trans zentrale freiheit
annehmen wie es eben kant getan hatte in
seiner kritik der reinen vernunft ja
dass ich will jetzt schon ein bisschen
vor spuren und da jetzt nicht mehr
weiter groß darauf eingehen und nur noch
zum schluss
klein vor blick geben auf den denker der
nächsten sitzung nämlich auf carl
christian schmid und der hat ein
interessantes schrift verfasst nämlich
den versuch eine moralphilosophie und in
dieser sitzung wollen wir uns dann eben
fragen wie fühlen sich die position von
ulrich schmid
inwiefern ist interpretation von kanzler
zeugen und was genau bis sagte intel
gibt eva canisius ich kann schon so viel
sagen dass auf jeden fall insofern eine
mehr gegeben ist zu spät oder zu ullrich
weil eben schmid einen schüler von
ulrich war und weil ullrich eine form
von determinismus vertreten hatte
die auch schmid sehr sehr attraktiv fand